what is your day-to-day habit that
turned you into a person that you are
now well in terms of the day that I have
it I think uh being curious I've been
curious about the world and how the
world works and curious about technology
and we're curious about everything
really I think curiosity is a very
important thing to have and then to be
somewhat obsessive about the Curiosity I
saw probably obsessive curiosity is
probably the number one thing and and I
think having a sort of a sense of
adventure is also good I think sometimes
people are afraid of things when they
shouldn't be afraid of things like you
want to make sure that your fear is
proportionate to the actual danger and I
think sometimes our instinctive fear is
not proportionate to the actual danger
so you want to try to rethink things
like just try to say okay is that fear
sometimes look at your instinctive fear
and question it and decide whether that
is you know really a valid fear or not
and often it is not and simply looking
at the fear will make it go away hey
seven Carmichael and I make these videos
because run into business is hard and
waking up every day and getting to work
when you're all by yourself is hard and
the thing that saved me that continues
to inspire me motivate me give me hope
inspiration ideas is looking at the
stories of people who've done a lot more
than me and I learn strategies I get
motivation and it gets me to believe in
myself to go off and attack the day and
so I hope this video inspires you to do
the same as well so today let's learn
the habits that made billionaires
wealthy enjoy
habit number two is never chase the hot
thing with Jeff Bezos is there any
advice that you would like to give to
people who would like to maybe go off on
their own start their own companies
things like that I mean you as being
sort of the king of entrepreneurs well I
would say
um yeah if uh
a couple of things one never chase the
hot thing whatever it is that's that's
like trying to catch the wave and you'll
never catch it you need to position
yourself and wait for the wave and the
way you do that is you pick something
you're passionate about so that that's
the number one piece of advice
that I give to somebody who wants to
start a company or or start a new
Endeavor inside of a bigger company make
sure it's something you're interested in
something you're passionate about
missionaries build better products
and so I would take a missionary over a
mercenary any day mercenaries want to
you know uh flip the company and get
rich missionaries want to build a great
product or service and you know one of
those great paradoxes It's usually the
missionaries who end up making more
money anyway habit number three is stand
out from the rest with Tillman Fertitta
the business is a sport and a
competitiveness just like basketball
football baseball or anything and it's
the competitiveness when I was 21 years
old I won my first Cadillac selling
shackley vitamins I told myself I wanted
to own my first jet at 35 and and did
you pull it off 100 yeah 100 and then
when I was in my 20s you know I said
when that Forbes 400 came out I said I
want to be on that list one day yeah so
you got to set yourself goals and try to
set yourself apart I talk about that in
the book is that anybody can set
themselves apart you can be the best
sound guy you can be the best cameraman
you can do so certain things and study
your field and then you get a break
because you were such a good cameraman
or you're the best sound guy that you
got recommended to go on this set and
then this set and then all of a sudden
in Hollywood you're known as the best
sound guy yeah you can do things to
separate yourself from everybody else by
just working a little harder I have a I
have a shirt that I wear I put a quote
on it be so good they can't ignore you
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there how about number four is never
stop learning with Warren Buffett I'm
wondering what habit or habits have
contributed most to your ability to
continue learning and improving your
investment decisions in a changing
business and financial environment
I would say that
at least in my case I haven't been
continually learning in terms of the
basic principles
you always learn a little more about
given techniques or we learn you know I
learn more about some Industries over
time and therefore maybe I've widened
the universe in which I can operate
although more funds narrows it back down
unfortunately but I know more about
businesses than I knew 20 years ago or
40 years ago
I haven't really changed the principles
the last change the basic principles are
still Ben Graham
they were affected in a significant Way
by Charlie and Phil Fisher in terms of
looking at the better businesses but
they but I didn't leave any of I didn't
leave Graham behind on that and I really
haven't learned any
any new fundamental principles but I may
have learned a little bit more about
how business operates over time
and there's really nothing I mean you
ought to you ought to get a investment
framework
that comes straight from in My View From
the intelligent investor and from Phil
Fisher
more from the intelligent investor
actually and then I think you ought to
learn everything you can about
Industries and businesses that where you
think you have the ability to get your
mind around them if you work at them and
and with that Arsenal you'll do very
well and if if you've got the
temperament for the business how about
number five is meditate with Tom bilyu
meditation is the biggest gift that I
can give anyone and I would say more
than anything it is whatever reason for
Success I've had because it allows one
back to the two U's I'll clarify what I
mean is that in your mind that we think
what do you want and the reality is when
you look at the neuroscience and
psychology that there are different
parts of your brain that want different
things
and so in the simplest sense there is
the logical part of the brain that
you're conscious of it's called the
conscious and you think you're being
logical and you want to make those
decisions
and then there's the subliminal below
the limbic system part of the brain
which is the emotional and it's not as
conscious to you but it has more of an
influence on you than really The Logical
one and so they're not aligned and so
when you're experiencing that pain or
let's say the ego right there were two
main things you got an ego barrier and a
blind spot barrier if you can get past
your ego barrier and you get past your
blind spot barrier you can accomplish
anything because you'll also know that
you don't have to do everything to you
don't have to figure it out yourself you
can take in from other people the
different ways to approach things in the
best possible way and so the realization
that we all are really struggling with
ourselves and to think which are which
is in control meditation helps to deal
with the alignment of those two things
because both are valuable in other words
intuition imagination the things we
really love come from our subliminal
uses right our needs whatever they may
be they come from here that's subliminal
they may be valuable they may be scared
damaging you don't know the difference
and so when they come up and you're
looking at those with your logical mind
and you can align those things you're
probably in good shape if you can do
that that alignment between the
subliminal and the logical and you can
do that with other people so that you
can triangulate with other people and
say does that make sense and get
alignment that alignment is the path to
the Future because you only have to know
what the best things to do are you don't
have to have them all come up from your
head and for God's sakes don't be overly
opinionated because just because you
have that opinion it doesn't mean it's
true so that's where the two use and the
alignment really is so important and
habit number six the last one before
some very special bonus Clips is work
productively with Charles Koch I
discovered at an early age I didn't
think I was much good at anything
and uh but my father did make me a big
favor he had me working in all my spare
time from the time I was six
because he he announced he didn't want
his sons to be Country Club bombs he
wanted us to feel grateful for
everything and entitled to nothing
and and for whatever reason when you say
working he didn't give you some cushy
office job in the company no no not
particularly at age six I started out
digging dandelions and when I say dig
dandelions you don't pull them out
and you have to get the entire route or
they'll come right back and I remember
there was a club and a swimming pool
across the street from us and I'm out
there in 105 degree heat digging these
and I could hear my friends my little
six-year-old friends they're swimming
and jumping off the diving board and I
could recognize each one squeal was
different with joy and I'm thinking
why does my father hate me and their
Father's Love
them I found out
that if you don't and then and then I of
course graduated to shoveling out stalls
and milking cows
and that doesn't sound like much work
but it's it's hard work so I would milk
cows before school and then again after
school milk milk or cows and digging
post holes and all these things
but I discovered that much later that if
if you don't learn to do dirty jobs if
you don't learn unpleasant work
you by the time you're in your 30s you
never learn to work productively and so
he was doing me a huge favor so it was
beyond the work ethic it taught you how
to work productively and how to work
with others in mutual benefit for
example if a group of you during a dirty
job you don't try to stick it to them
make them do more then they'll try to do
it to you and the work goes on and on
you want to work together to get it done
as efficiently as possible you want to
understand who your customer is how do
what if my customer want what what does
he value I better do this the right way
or I'll have to do it again
I know you all have big goals Big Dreams
big aspirations just like I do you got
Ambitions to become an amazing person to
build your career to create contribute
to give to be an awesome human being but
all of that is impossible without great
habits set up if you don't have routine
and structure set up in a way that will
keep you on track then you'll you'll
fall off and and having new goals
without new habits is kind of like you
know having a new car without wheels you
know the habits are the wheels they're
the things that make you able to achieve
the goals so you got to have good habits
but the challenge for most people isn't
that knowledge I mean you know you need
to have good habits it's you can't keep
the Habit going right have you ever
started it the new year you're going to
get healthier and you start that habit
of working out on a more regular basis
and then it goes away or you say you
know I'm going to be more kind and more
patient and more awesome to my partner
my lover and you start being nice for
two or three days and then on the fourth
day you're jerk you know and you're like
why what happened I said I was gonna be
nicer it's that you didn't set up the
most important thing you needed to
maintain a habit so what's the biggest
secret I've learned in almost 20 years
in this field it's so simple but most
people don't have it it's called trigger
moments
you have to set up trigger moments to
activate your habits what do I mean by
that well let's say you want to become a
better person you know you want to
become more kind more patient more
loving with people now you can just set
that intention or write that down in
your vision in your journal or set up on
a vision board that you look at once in
a while but in day-to-day life it's not
enough you need things to trigger you to
remind you to be that particular kind of
person right it's almost like if you
could have a little angel speaking in
your ear all day long to tell you what
to do and how to be you'd obviously
become better well that makes sense well
let's use that idea let's use that idea
by setting up alarms on our phones that
trigger us to do the very things we need
to do this can be so basic you're going
to laugh and then also tell you how I've
literally taught this to Fortune 50 CEOs
and they said it was the one thing that
changed their life the most dramatically
so let's start with this let's I have a
goal in mind let's say you want to
become more present and calm throughout
the day again you could write that down
on a journal I'm going to be more
present and calm you can meditate in the
morning say today don't be more present
and calm and you're gonna you could you
could start out with good intentions but
those fall apart without a trigger
moment set up throughout the day to
remind you that so what if you did this
what if you just set up on your phone
three alarms during the day with a label
that said
close your eyes
take 10 deep breaths in remind yourself
to be calm
so let's say you're going through your
day it's crazy right it's 10 a.m and
also Bing your phone goes off you look
down and it says close your eyes take 10
deep breaths and then again it happens
at two o'clock and again it happens at 6
pm and again it happens at 8pm what's
gonna happen you always look at your
phone don't you it's going to go
throughout the day you're going to
forget and the funniest thing is I've
had so many people do this worldwide
we're talking about hundreds of
thousands of people I've taught to do
this hundreds of thousands and they tell
me all the time that changed everything
and you'll think once you set it up that
the next day you you'll you'll forget
about it no that alarm will go off you
forgot you set the dang alarm there it
goes off in your face you're like all
right I'm trying to be calmer and more
present close my eyes take 10 deep
breaths re-ground myself here we go you
can't do it once a day you have to have
moments throughout the day that trigger
you to enact the new Behavior I know
this makes sense to you but it's a
challenge for a lot of people because
they never set those things up so what
if you did it with an alarm
so for example for me on the opposite
Spectrum I don't want to just be calmer
and more present I Want More Energy
throughout the day so here's what I do
one of my big trigger moments is every
time my butt hits a chair I don't care
if I'm on a plane or I was like where
we're shooting here I I wrote a lot of
my books here I wrote the motivation
Manifesto here I wrote The Charge here
and if I'm going to write my butt hits
the chair I grab my phone I open the
timer and I set 50 minutes
now at 50 minutes the timer goes it
starts buzzing and I look at that and I
go oh that's my trigger to get energy so
I stand up I go get some water I take a
glass of water drink it down I do some
stretches and I do some exercise just
really briefly or I'll go for a walk
whatever it is but I'll do something
that usually takes just two to five
minutes
then I'll sit back down I'll set that 50
minute alarm and I'll work
and what that does is every 50 minutes
it triggers me to change how I'm
physically moving it changes my
attention so that throughout the day I'm
continually refreshed so I never have
that two three four o'clock time where
I'm like ah you know why because I've
triggered my day so that my energy is
maintained throughout the day makes
sense right this could be as simple as
let's say you want to be healthier in
your life okay let's set up some trigger
moments for you in this way let's say
every time you drop off the kids on the
way back to the house you stop at the
grocery store and get some fresh produce
that's just a trigger it's like okay did
one thing drop kids off now tied to that
triggered from that action drop kids off
is go to health food store or let's say
you want to get healthier in the morning
one of the easiest ways to help people
maintain a better exercise program is
this
set a trigger you wake up in the morning
your first action is to drink water put
your exercise shoes on uh might get
dressed if you were naked just saying so
you get dressed put your shoes on you go
downstairs or you go to the gym and
that's the trigger you woke up you do
these actions nothing interrupts those
actions that's the action and you have
to have those set up one of my other
favorite trigger moments to set up is
door frame triggers what do you remember
that when you walk into a new room
to have a psychological trigger go off
in your mind that you've associated with
that door frame so let me give you an
example if I walk into my house at night
after if I've been working all day and
I'm going to walk in I'm gonna see my
lady I have it so when I ever walk
through the doors of my house three
words repeat off immediately in my mind
because I've done it so many times
consciously I went to the door I said
the three words said three words said
the three words and I did this so many
times and now when I walk through a door
my mind automatically triggers those
three words and I remember to be those
three words so what words would you love
to have describe you as a person that
you would be happy if that was how
people described you what would those
words be have those and now set them up
in your life I teach Executives to do
this as well I have them have a door
frame trigger when they walk into their
office in the morning as soon as they
walk through that door frame they have
boom three words go through their mind
about how they want to be perceived as a
leader I haven't set up another door
frame every time they walk into a
meeting into the conference room when
they walk through the doors of the
conference room they have another three
words that trigger off for them and it
just reminds them how to be
so these are Big crazy things a lot of
people think they have to completely
change their life what would change your
life completely is setting up more
trigger moments and associations that
when you see something you do this that
when this action is taken then that
happens that when you uh have the
opportunity to set up alarms on your
phone you set them up so that you're
interrupted in your everyday life to
remind yourself to stick to the habits
to stick to the intention you do that
enough on a continual basis you'll find
yourself in so many ways completely
rejuvenated and I promise you'll stick
to your habits even more and once you do
that you know that everything changes
when it comes to an affirmation
affirmations can be powerful uh
and for some people they're not
and a lot of people say well you know if
the the affirmation is so powerful how
come I'm not experiencing the effect the
what scientists tell us is the average
human
speaks to themselves consciously or
unconsciously we have thoughts spinning
around in our brain about 60 to 80
000 thoughts per day some of those
thoughts are the words to the songs and
they are the affirmations
uh neuroscientist Andrew nurburg tells
us Newberg is his name I'm sorry and um
in his work that that a single word a
single word has the power to to change
the genes that creates stress or relieve
stress in our lives he's telling us that
that something within us has the ability
to shift at the very core of our
expression so we know that words are are
powerful the key to a successful
affirmation is that we must communicate
with the subconscious part of our of our
mind number one number two we must
communicate in the language that the
subconscious recognizes
and this is where uh you know you can
say
I had a friend of mine when I was
working in the corporations that had
affirmations all over his office all
over his computer screen they were on
little Post-it notes in the car we would
carpool in you know my Perfect Mate is
manifesting for me now my Perfect Mate
is manifesting for me now that was his
affirmation and I said do you say these
things he goes oh man I say I'm about a
million times a day I said do they work
for you he says Nah
you know these these things don't work
and I said why do you think they don't
work and he said look at me he says I'm
an engineer I'm a slob he said I wear
the same clothes to work three out of
five days during the week you know and
and it the the bottom line by the time
he finished describing himself to me
even he didn't believe that he was
worthy of his Perfect Mate manifesting
for him now so he was saying the words
but he was not there was the the
underlying emotion and what he was
actually feeding into his his system was
counter to what those words were saying
so it's it's not enough to say the words
when we go into our most ancient and
cherished spiritual Traditions those
words are what become the prayers
and for many people I have and I know
you've heard this as well a lot of
people feel that prayer is broken that
the world doesn't work today the way it
worked in biblical times
that we have lost our power and that we
have no ability to communicate with a
greater power with god with the forces
around us and it's largely because
the secrets the Deep truth of our
relationship
fundamental physics of our relationship
to our world uh have been minced and
parceled and in many cases deleted from
the texts leaving us with a sense that
we are essentially powerless beings and
if you are powerless then you are a
victim and if you're a victim you need a
savior and that savior is coming to us
on a silver plate in terms of technology
in terms of political leaders I will
save you if you just do these things
and this is why I say I think one of the
most the most powerful acts and the most
radical act we can do is to think for
ourselves uh original thinking based
upon the Deep truth of our relationship
to our bodies in the earth not based
upon the false assumptions of obsolete
science that permeate our academic world
right now it's one of the reasons I left
Academia it's one of the reasons many of
my colleagues who are in this genre who
are very well respected scientists have
left Academia because they were not
allowed to share with students and in
their writings and their papers what
they had found in their research that
reflects a very different reality now
it's for me it's it's a uh it's good
news it's a beautiful message of Hope
and possibility
uh as a sovereign biological being
for a system that's based on centralized
power and control it's probably the
worst news they could imagine because it
means we don't need the centralized
power and control I think ultimately
we're all better off by embracing our
own power because it frees us from the
fear of a changing world and we all know
our world my world is changing your
world is changing nor has it ever faster
than we can document it in our
classrooms and textbooks
but the change isn't necessarily bad
until we compare it to what we've known
in the past and this is where the fear
comes in
so the the new discoveries helping us to
understand
we are part of rather than separate from
our world and this is this is where the
affirmations come in so
in I was at the CERN superconducting
super collider in Geneva Switzerland
where the the physics experiments that
are revealing
what happened moments after our universe
began they recreate
the the beginning of our universe and
then they're able to document what
happened then to create the laws of
physics that we are experiencing that
we're living under right now
and what they announced in 2012 is that
there is in fact a field
an intelligent field of energy it's a
subtle energy that underlies all of
creation
um before then it was a metaphor or a
lot of people felt like it was a new age
concept you know we are all one
everything is is connected or an
indigenous you know a lot of indigenous
Elders talk about this here's here's
where they got stuck
and I've gone to Scientific conferences
where they'll take their hands and
they'll say oh yeah there's that's
that's no longer controversial there is
a field there's a field out there that
connects all things and their hands go
like this there's a field out there that
connects all things because
subconsciously they're still saying
we're separate from that field right but
here's what the science is showing us
and this this was a game changer for me
uh just a mind blower that every atom
in every molecule and every cell of our
bodies in this very instant
so it's not like it's about to happen
it's it's happening right now every atom
is constantly emerging and collapsing
into that field
and what that says to us is that we are
the field it's not the fields out there
we literally are wrinkles we are
disturbances in this field this this
body
that is held in place by a conscious
awareness as long as I'm breathing on
this Earth
I am a disturbance I'm a localized
Wrinkle in that field and what that
means
is that if I want to bring about change
in my world I don't have to force a
change out there I become that change
and as I have become that change the
field is now reflecting what it is
because I'm part of the field so it's a
subtle but it's a very powerful way a
very different way of thinking you're
not you're not imposing change on the
world around you
you are becoming the change so you're
becoming the abundance you're becoming
uh the love the Gratitude the care
uh the healing you're becoming those
things and that is very different we're
conditioned to ask for them to plead for
them because we're led to feel powerless
in our lives when in fact there are
modalities of ancient prayer that were
edited
from the the religious texts in the
fourth Century by the church they took
they took out the information helping us
to understand that this this deep
relationship leaving us powerless and
and affirmations are essentially a a
form of Prayer
our prayer is a form of affirmation
however you want to look at it where we
are communicating and I want to be
really clear it's not about control it's
not about manipulation it's not about
imposing our will it's about
participating
in the way that this field unfolds and
expresses in in our lives and when you
really begin to get that shift
it's it's subtle and it's powerful it's
not making something happen out there
and that means you can't blame what's
out there for your experiences I I come
from a very dysfunctional broken family
and I had to make a choice early in life
as to whether or not I would and
Community as to whether or not I would
allow that to Define
my my experience to Define my existence
other people around me had the same
experience and they made very different
choices they today continue to blame
their environment their parents their
family their upbringing
for the sad and unfortunate things in
their lives and and that's a path it's
not right wrong good or bad but we have
a choice to make another path and when
we began as a scientist beginning to
understand these relationships gave me
the reason to think differently
and it also gave me the reason to test
in my life
if those thoughts are really true or not
what works and what doesn't one of the
things that will help you to do the work
to create the things that you want in
your life is it will help you if you
train your mind
to start spotting evidence as you're
doing the work as you're going through
your day it will help you if you train
your mind to start scanning the world
and spotting evidence that yes indeed
the world is sending you positive
signals that things are going to work
out now why is it important to train
your mind to help you get what you want
well the reason why is because if you
get into a negative mindset if you start
thinking
this business is never going to work why
even bother I'm never going to meet
anybody it's nothing but losers out
there look at all these idiots on hinge
why the hell should I keep doing this if
you allow your mind to start to rest in
a pessimistic negative protective scared
and doubtful stance your mind will
continue to show you reasons why there's
nobody on hinge worth talking to your
mind will continue to show you all the
reasons why you will never make it in
business your mind will continue to show
you all the reasons why you're never
going to lose that weight and be able to
tuck in your shirt as my friend Corinne
Crabtree always talks about that
transformational moment and when your
mind goes negative your mind starts to
scan the world and will show you more
reasons to stop and the power of
training your mind to spot positive
signs is very simple the power is that
your mind will start to show you reasons
to keep going your mind will help you
take the step your mind will encourage
you to feel optimistic to feel empowered
just like you woke up today on a Tuesday
and it was February 22nd 2022 and those
numbers are lining up and that makes you
in your heart and soul go whoa something
cool could happen today like that
only happens like once in my lifetime
those numbers are going to line up like
that today is a really cool date let's
go do something with this you could
create that kind of attitude every
single freaking day of your life you
could if you train your mind and if you
start taking action and training your
mind is the key piece that we're going
to talk about
so for those of you that have read the
high five habit one of the things that I
talk about a lot is every single day
find a naturally occurring heart-shaped
object in the world it could be a stone
it could be a leaf it could be a cloud
it could be a shape in your coffee hey
Chris if we've got anything around here
that looks like a heart hand it to me
and the reason why I love telling you to
start playing a game with yourself well
you start your day going mind brain show
me some heart oh what is this come here
dog treat oh my God it's a dog treat
look at this guys
what shape is that
that right there is a harp
there we go check that out if you say
brain mind show me a heart today guess
what's gonna happen that damn dog
biscuit it's gonna show it's gonna
you're gonna be like there's a heart
you're gonna look out at the sky and
you're gonna see a heart shape oh right
there in the mountains there's a heart
shape in the mountains in southern
Vermont you're going to see it in the
clouds what you're doing when you tell
your mind what's important to you is
you're telling your mind and the filter
in your brain to change in real time and
allow into your consciousness
what's important to you and if you want
to see hearts by God those damn dog
treats are going to start looking like
hearts everybody that's how you train
your mind it's freaking incredible and
if you want to see evidence of this
follow me on social media if you follow
me Mel Robbins on social media you will
see every day I am reposting your
stories of finding heart shapes around
the world now why is this important well
it's important because it's a simple way
to prove to you that your mind changes
in real time that if you get serious
about becoming more positive and
optimistic and encouraging of yourself
if you get serious about saying this I
don't want to see all the reasons why
I'm unhappy I don't want to see
everybody else in the world that's
launched a business or that's lost
weight and is healthy or that has a
really good marriage or relationship and
I don't want to see that and and have my
mind process it as evidence that it's
never going gonna happen for me I want
my mind to reprogram itself and see
other people's businesses and see other
people getting healthy and see other
people in relationships and I want my
mind to say yeah if they can do it I can
do it that's evidence if that person can
get healthy so can I if that person can
find somebody on hinge so can I if that
person can reconcile with their child so
can I other people can become evidence
that you can have it too right now your
mind is so up from your past that
when you see what other people have and
you don't have it you can't actually
translate it through a negative mind and
and see that that's evidence that you're
going to win you see it like oh somebody
already stole what I wanted that sucks
and so what I want to start to open your
mind to is that you have the power to
train your mind
to filter the world differently just
like you woke up and you saw the date
today 2 22 22 and your brain saw that
was like whoa this is a once in a
lifetime day everybody
you are never going to have another day
that lines up like this ever
what are you gonna do with this day your
mind already interpreted this as wow
something cool could happen
and if you tell yourself something
amazing is going to happen today
something will because you're going to
be looking for it I swear to God
something will
something will if you want to see the
good all around you you got to tell your
mind you want to see the good and this
just isn't a bunch of horsesh everybody
this isn't toxic positivity there is a
filter in your brain called a reticular
activating system
the reticular activating system I call
it the RAS I like to think about it like
a giant hair net on your head and this
Ras sits over your brain I'm probably
getting this wrong I'm not a
neuroscientist I could give a sh about
getting it right I just need you to know
the basics here so that you can apply it
to your life okay you don't need a PhD
to use the science that super smart
people have been working really hard on
in order to apply it to your life that's
what I'm here for in your life I'm here
to translate this stuff into simple
believable and actionable things that
you can do to take all this super cool
stuff that people are researching and
apply it to your normal person's
everyday life to help you change from
the inside out and one of the coolest
things that you have at your disposal is
you have a whole system in your body
that you can train and change and one of
those things that you can train and
change that is impacted by that real
that word you're hearing a lot of
neuroplasticity that just means that
things are able to twist and bend and
change and you're able to learn new
things for as long as you're alive as
long as you're breathing everybody you
got a chance to change the way that you
think as long as you are breathing you
got a chance to change from the inside
out how you experience your life as long
as you are still here watching me people
you got a chance to create a new
experience in your life and one of the
things that helps a lot is understanding
that right now all of the bullsh from
your past has jammed the filter in your
mind body and spirit the reticular
activating system and it is clouding
your ability to look at the world around
you and see hearts remember this dog
treat hearts look at that there's a
heart right there you wanted to be a
professional baseball player right yeah
but then you got an injury they did
similar to me so you never made it to
the big leagues or did you play minor
league I did yeah and I played division
one college baseball too yeah I like
every guy like you and I talked about
this last time it's always our injuries
that ended our careers I probably it
probably put me into a premature place
where I was going anyways you aren't
going to be in The Bigs for I wasn't I
played enough baseball with guys who
ended up in the big leagues to know my
limitations yeah so like anything in
life things happen for you not to you
that injury happened for me it certainly
didn't seem like it at the time but it
got me out of that and into something
like what we're talking about now that
completely changed my life so yeah but
yeah I want to be an athlete for sure
all my life all your life that was my
mask and then when it exactly and then
when it ended your identity was like who
am I right yes lost yeah like a lot you
and I were just talking before we went
on yeah you know our professional
athlete friends were their career
changes I went into a like anybody like
whatever your dream is when the first
one ends it doesn't happen whether that
be a relationship it could be your
marriage events it was a dream right or
a business venture or a sport I went
into a pretty good depression and uh and
how old were you at the time 21 22 and I
ended up you know it's because people
always see the after like the house or
whatever houses or whatever the material
things are but I ended up bad man I
ended up to press I ended up moving back
at home with my parents I was living in
the city I remember I was living in this
sleeping in the same bed I grew up in
with the same teddy bear the same
posters I was like going back in time
like six years on back where I was
totally unemployed and uh couldn't find
work didn't have the motivation to get
up and find a job just sort of eating
out of their fridge and laying around
all day so that's where I was many many
years ago after baseball and when you
realize things in your life happen for
you truly especially in hindsight
everybody knows it in hindsight right if
you look back at any disaster tragedy
most people look back five ten years
they think that happened for me that was
actually a good thing and so I was
unemployed I couldn't find a job and my
old man my dad dad was the best dad role
model you could ever have in your life
hard-working man good man it's better
man than me has more Integrity than me
he's the best man I've ever known but
when I was growing up my dad had a
drinking problem and so my dad had
gotten sober recently and he was going
to these meetings and he comes home from
one of his meetings and says there's a
guy at my meeting who can get you a job
it's right down the street in San Dimas
you're going to be working with kids
doesn't pay anything at six bucks an
hour but you're gonna get this damn job
so show up there tomorrow morning 8 A.M
ask for Tim so I walked out I drive down
there it's a place called McKinley Home
For Boys little did I know that would
alter
my entire life that was the most
significant thing that happened to me
and so I walk in there I said I'm Ed
mylett I'm here for the job you're like
what job I'm like I don't know just my
dad told me to show up here yeah I need
to ask for Tim they're like
we have no idea who the hell Tim is
what's his last name I said I I don't I
don't know his last name and they're
like so you showed up for a job that you
don't know what it is and you don't know
who it is that's hiring you I'm like
here's what I know he's an alcoholic I'm
like oh damn yeah we know that too and
so they bring me to the guy and he says
uh you're hired let's go like literally
shakes my hand and you're hired and he
introduces me to these eight boys that
were my boys they were seven eight and
nine years old and basically I lived
with these boys these precious boys and
we ended up adding a few more my boys
were all Wards of the Court they were
all molested by family where parents
were in prison and so they had no family
and so my whole life changed all of a
sudden these became on this 22 year old
guy these guys become my sons wow and I
did holidays with them I did birthdays
with them I lived with them literally in
a home or like a literally McKinley is a
massive campus full of children that
have been displaced from their homes
that live in individual like Cottages
like a foster care facility massive
though really yeah all boys
it's in San Dimas here and um wow it
just altered my life man because I I'd
been an athlete had a huge ego had that
mask I wanted to compete I wanted to win
I wanted attention I wanted recognition
first time literally in my life I went
while I I love helping people I love
making a difference and my boys were
just come from horrendous situations and
so just I always say this all the time
and I have those eyes too you have them
I think sometimes kids who grow up with
some dysfunction they just have
different eyes yeah they just have these
eyes that are these boys all were
different but they had that same eyes
they're just like man love me believe in
me you know care about me and I had
those eyes because I grew up in an
alcoholic family and my whole life
changed I just went wow I love I
actually love helping people and being
involved in people's lives I didn't know
that because everything was you're great
you're great you know what it is when
you're an athlete right everything's
about you you're amazing free dinners
free this you're a stud all of a sudden
I wasn't a stud and all of a sudden it
wasn't about me it was about these 10
boys that ended up being 10 of them and
it just altered my life man and so after
that I ran into the financial business
that I ended up in but I would have
completely flunked out of that Financial
business had I not been with my boys for
those years and I was there for two
years two years yeah man like eight
hours a day type of thing or sometimes
more sometimes 16 18. I I think about
I'm not kidding you I think about my
boys and my experience there two of them
are still very close with me uh every
day there's a moment where I reflect on
that it altered me completely like what
I wanted to do I always wanted to be
famous and Rich and successful and now I
just wanted to serve yeah I wanted to
help a little did I find out I could get
rich and famous and all that other stuff
I thought I wanted through serving
people if you think that your thoughts
have something to do with your future
just from a theoretical standpoint that
your thoughts Create Your Destiny and
you think sixty to seventy thousand
thoughts in one day and ninety percent
of those thoughts are the same thoughts
as the day before well then your life
isn't going to change very much as long
as you're thinking the same way and
those those same thoughts lead to the
same choices the same choices lead to
the same behaviors the same behaviors
create the exact exact same experiences
and we anticipate the same feelings or
emotions from those experiences and
those emotions are the payoff that drive
our very same thoughts well our biology
our neuroscircuitry our neural chemistry
our hormones and even our gene
expression will be equal to how we think
how we act and how we feel and how we
think how we act and how we feel is
called our personality and our
personality creates our personal reality
that's it so the present personality
who's listening to this show has created
the present personal reality called
their life so if you can latch on to
this idea if you want to create a new
life a new personal reality you got to
change your personality which means you
better start thinking about what you've
been thinking about and changing it you
begin to become conscious of your
unconscious actions or habits or
behaviors and modify them
and then we have to begin to look at the
emotions that we live by every single
day
that'll keep us connected to the past
and decide do these emotions belong in
our future so most people are trying to
create a new personal reality as the
same personality and it doesn't work you
literally have to become someone else so
the principle of Neuroscience says that
nerve cells that fire together wire
together you keep thinking the same way
making the same choices demonstrating
the same habits creating the same
experiences that stamp the same networks
of neurons into the same patterns all
for the familiar feeling called you and
you do that for 10 years on end you're
going to begin to hardwire certain
patterns in your brain that becomes your
identity and by the time we're 35 years
old it kind of becomes fixed right and
psychology used to say that you can't
change that but we now know that you can
so then
that kind of box in the brain that is
the habit of ourselves it's a we're 95
of the time running a series of programs
so then sitting and doing the work had
we have to become disentangled from
those programs and so the moment you
decide to do something differently
you're making a choice but most people
don't want to face is that discomfort
and that that discomfort that that
uncertainty that lack of predictability
the that that that unknown is what
people are afraid of because they'd
rather live in guilt at least they can
predict who they're going to be then
take a chance and possibility so when a
person begins to understand this and you
say well
how long have you been this way and they
say I've been like this for 35 years and
you say why 35 years because 35 years
ago I had this one event well the
stronger the emotion you feel from
reaction from that event the more
altered you feel inside of you the more
the brain Narrows its focus and freezes
the image and takes a snapshot and
that's called a memory right so then
forget the memory just overcome the
emotion because it's the emotion that
keeps you anchored to the past so that
sounds really good theoretically but
when you step out into that unknown into
that void
the body really is in a habit and what a
habit is when the body becomes the mind
or if you're thinking about that past
event and is producing an emotion well
you need an image and a feeling to start
the conditioning process so the body's
either conditioned into the familiar
past or it's hardwired in the
predictable future because it wakes up
every single day and runs through the
same series of routine actions so the
present moment then becomes the unknown
when people start feeling that
discomfort today they rather get on
their cell phone and call someone or get
up and say I can't meditate or you know
I have too much to do they excuse
themselves they return back into that
familiar feeling because the body's
actually telling the brain The Habit is
when the body becomes the mind so the
body stepping out into the unknown and
says ooh I'd rather feel guilty I'd
rather feel unhappy
than be in this this conference so then
at least then when they return back to
that familiar feeling then they feel
safe so they step out in the unknown and
the body starts influencing the mind
saying you can start tomorrow you're too
busy it's your mother's fault you know
it's your culture's fault and I don't
have enough money this isn't going to
work
those are the programs in there that are
standing in the way between you and your
future so then nerve cells that no
longer fire together no longer wire
together so the act of observing those
states of Mind and Body
means you're no longer the program
you're the Consciousness observing that
program so so then
to meditate it means to become familiar
with so as you become familiar with
those thoughts you become conscious of
how you speak you become aware of how
you act you notice how you're feeling
the more conscious you become of those
unconscious programs the less
unconscious you'll go in your waking day
why because it's not enough to just have
a great meditation and get up and get on
the freeway and get in traffic and
getting stressed you just return back to
the old self again our job then is to
sustain that modified State of Mind and
Body the entire day and if you can get
ready because something different or
unusual is going to begin to happen in
your life and it will come as a
coincidence or a synchronicity and
that's breadcrumbs from the Divine
saying you're on the path just keep
doing it there'll be another one just
keep staying in that energy and so
teaching people then to understand that
there's a formula that we now know that
if you apply that formula you'll begin
to see those changes and now as people
are doing it more and more
effectively the results are going up as
well we just had Bond University they
just took a whole bunch of my brain
scans from 10 years ago
huge clinical study a lot of analysis
and and they're Blown Away by the speed
in which
uh the community can change brain or
heart coherence they they know how to do
it it's not uh something that's that's
separate from them they've practiced it
enough times that they they now know how
to do it so what's the significance of
that well really simple in your life
if you start returning back to the same
reactions to the same people and
circumstances you're returning back to
the old self so you got to stay
conscious in your life and and if you're
not being defined by a vision of the
future then you're left with the
memories of the past and you will be
predictable in your life so Crossing
that River of change from the old self
to the new self there's a neurological a
biological chemical hormonal a genetic
death of the old self but if you teach
people there's something on the other
side they won't give up on themselves
they'll keep going so there's enough
evidence to encourage people and you
can't tell me you're too old to do this
work you can't tell me you're too sick
to do this work you can't tell me you
had a turbulent past or or that you're
too overweight or too underweight or too
out of shape or you can't even tell me
that you've never meditated before in
fact some of our greatest
scans or people who just have never
meditated before that are not trying to
do anything they just follow
instructions so
our community now is beginning to
understand that it is possible and they
go all in not 50 and not sixty percent
and when we do a week-long event we got
a thousand people or 1500 people and
they are all in and that when they start
getting Beyond themselves that first day
or second day once they start getting
Beyond themselves and that magic starts
to happen then I have no idea I can't
predict what's going to happen next and
it's usually pretty pretty exciting you
have a single most important core value
and when you figure it out your entire
life changes if you feel like you're
being pulled in a million different
directions
you're walking on quicksand everybody
wants something from you you're hot and
cold you want to do something one day
and you don't the other day you have a
hard time saying no to people and to
Opportunities and you're just being
pulled in a thousand directions does
that sound familiar does it sound like
you
if that's you
you don't know what you stand for
because when you know what you stand for
all decisions become easier
I wrote two books on this your one word
and then built the serve and at the core
both of them is figuring out what what
do you stand for what is your single
most important core value and when you
can name it when you can label it when
you can get to the root of it what it
does is give you Clarity for the rest of
your life
minus belief my one word is belief
I want to believe in myself more and I
want to spread belief to the world to
the people around me it's why I make all
these videos
I make them for myself because I need to
learn and I want to be around the best I
want to be around people who inspire me
to believe more in myself and I try to
spread that to the world
it becomes a filter through which I see
the world it becomes the filter through
which my best self operates
whenever I don't know what to do
whenever I'm given an opportunity
whenever I might be pulled in a thousand
different directions
what do I run that through is we'll
believe
what would the believe version of Evan
do what would he do
and then that just makes it easier
boom decision made
easier
if you look at my YouTube Channel people
say well you do all these top 10 rules
and you do all these inspiring videos
it's great why not do top 10 of
the stupidest things this person said
her top 10 reasons why not to follow
this person
if I did that if I if I went negative on
Kanye West or Donald Trump or whoever
those videos would actually do better
you know this is where it gets really
tough this is where it really comes down
to what you stand for and how much do
you stand for
because when you can get to the core of
who you are that becomes a lot easier
because
making those videos if I was to slam
people
would do better people would much rather
watch negative videos than positive
people would much rather laugh at
somebody else than educate themselves
it's just just how we always rather
watch
big brother and watch reality TV shows
and people tearing each other apart you
can't look away from a car accident or
fight on the street we have this thing
inside us where we like seeing other
people
not doing well because that's how we
feel better about ourselves when you see
somebody else struggling to see someone
else's terrible life on TV you feel
better about yourself so we have this we
have this insecurity inside all of us
and so those videos would do better or
top 10 stupidest things Kanye West has
said would would get more views would
make me more money would lead to more
subscribers would lead to all the
metrics that
that you would probably look at right
you know if I look at well what are my
goals do I want more subscribers more
views more comments more Revenue it
would help all of that
but it's anti-belief
I don't want I feel gross I don't want
to put that content out I don't want to
put up content slamming people it's not
who I am it's not what makes me come
alive
and this is where you could do it for a
short amount of time and you're going to
start to burn out because you start to
hate your life because you're doing work
that is just against who you want to be
you look at Dave Hollis he's got his one
word of Captain great so what does a
captain do
Captain goes through choppy Waters
Captain is built for the rough Seas
so if he's ever stuck thinking about
should I do this or not well what would
a captain do
and then boom answer
so figuring out your one word figuring
out that most important core value what
it does is give you a roadmap
for the rest of your life and it it
never gets old I will never stop
believing
in myself and others and wanting to
continue to inspire Dave Hollis will
never stop wanting to be the captain
and you need to figure out what yours is
because that gives you direction again
for the rest of your life so how do we
do it how do what are some of the
tactics what are some of the tricks that
you can use because I think this is one
of the most important exercises you can
ever do in your life understanding what
you stand for as a human
it's not it's not taught you know in
schools it's not taught in textbooks
most of the people who've taught you in
schools they're not happy with the
direction of their life either right
like as you start to get older when
you're when you're a kid and you look at
your parents and adults you feel like
they got it all figured out they have
the answers and then you realize they
have no idea what they're doing like
they're barely hanging on themselves
the teachers who taught you about you
know life in in school they're not happy
with their own life
they haven't figured this out either
but I think it's one of the most
important things that we can learn so
again I have two books on it your one
word built to serve you want to go
deeper those are great resources but you
start with what are some of the things
that make you come alive
who was your favorite teacher growing up
what movies did you love growing up what
did you love about how your parents
raised you even if you hate your parents
was there anything that you can pull out
that you loved
and what you're doing is looking at what
are some of the things that tie these
things together
so if you had the right this is the
exercise I do with people
okay tell me your favorite movie and
three words to describe it
tell me who your favorite teacher was
and three words to describe them think
about your favorite teacher growing up
favorite coach your favorite mentor
because they taught you grade eight
science
right it wasn't the material they taught
you they made you feel better as a human
they taught you how to be a better
person why what did they do
I was talking to a woman yesterday
coaching her through this process we did
Instagram live together she's part of my
movement makers program and just past a
year being in the program so we did a
live together and she wanted to go
through this exercise how do I find my
one word
and her favorite teacher growing up
wasn't a teacher but was her coach she
was a track coach and one of the things
that she loved about the track coach was
he would get in and do it with her
so whenever she was tired whenever she
wanted to quit whenever she didn't feel
good enough he wouldn't just give her
words but he would do it with her he'd
say okay
I'll do the last one with you race me
and he would run alongside her
so as you think about it what what was
your favorite teacher growing up who was
it and and why write down
some descriptive keywords and what
you'll find is if you do that with who
your favorite mentors are who your
favorite teachers are what your favorite
books or videos are look at my Channel
all the people we profiled and who were
the people that you resonate with the
most if you love me what are three words
about Evan Carmichael that you love you
love Dave paulus what are three words
that describe Dave Hollis you know all
the good things that that you love that
make you feel alive and bold and
confident and serving and wanting to
help all those things are connected
but they don't feel connected this is
the problem this is the the connective
tissue work that you have to do this is
where
we never learn these things the things
that you love are not just random
occurrences they're connected
when you write them down the descriptive
keywords you'll see a trend that happens
between them
so for me it's belief my favorite movie
is Seabiscuit it's about a horse that's
too small and a jockey that's too big
and a team owner that's going bankrupt
and somehow they come together find each
other and win all of these races and
it's based off a true story and they go
and beat the the well-funded you know
the team that has the perfect jockey and
the giant horse and the tons of money
and they go and they beat those guys
right so if I were to write down you
know the three words believe is on there
I might say Underdog I might say
inspiring they might say believe I would
say believe you know and then if I think
about my favorite teacher growing up
Madame Farr taught me French but I don't
even use my French like French isn't
even that valuable for the work that I
do why do I love Madame Farr well
because she believed in me because she
would meet with me once a week when I
was in my
graduating year
and
she just asked me about my life how I
was doing in school I was introverted I
was shy
you know it was harder for me to make
friends and feel like I fit in and
belonged and so for her I might put
belong I would definitely put the leave
and I might put something else maybe
care or compassion
in those meetings with her once a week
turned me from a BNC student into a
straight A student when I didn't think
that that was possible for for me to do
it because I never really gotten A's my
entire School career so
we start to look at the similarities
right but I'm far
believe you know compassion Etc
Seabiscuit Underdog believe right
there's different keywords that will
show up but what's a consistent one
believe
Ah that's interesting
this interesting this keeps coming up
what would happen if I built my whole
life around belief what would happen if
I built my business around belief what
would happen if I created a schedule
and a calendar and habits and routines
that made me feel more belief what would
happen if I could spread that belief to
others what would happen if I brought on
team members who love believe and helped
spread believe with their skills and
talents what would happen if I had my
significant other
believe in me right what would happen
What would how much has life changed
free thing Everything Changes because
now I'm designing a life
with intent
purpose
and with design
as opposed to randomly having things
experienced for me to me because
everybody's got an agenda for your time
everybody wants you to do certain things
and that's when you feel lost and being
pulled in a million different directions
you have to figure out what you stand
for I think it's the most important
thing you can do as a human what do you
stand for what's your single most
important core value
some people get it right away from the
exercises some people take some time and
you you sit on it and it becomes more
and more right or more and more wrong
but when you find it
and you get that Compass you get that
road map it's with you for the rest of
your life it makes every decision easier
it makes you live a lot more in
alignment and makes you feel like what
you're doing is important that it
matters it gives you the confidence and
the courage to the thing that you're
afraid to do to step outside your
comfort zone to build the business and
the life that you want
and ultimately to make you happy
to make you happy
and then you can spread that happiness
to others will help them believe in
themselves too
[Music]
yo I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to learn
how to brainwash yourself for Success
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there every morning I
wake up it's not just about working out
but for me working out has been a very
big part of my mental growth so for me
if I am not challenging myself every day
and I swear to God people will not
believe it